capitaine
et ben Johnny parce qu'on dit tu sors
aujourd'hui écoute vu que je serai que
la liberté
c'est pour savoir à la maison
allons-y on a des choses à régler suivez
pas vrai il est où notre ancienne maison
on a cherché partout sauf j'aurais
jamais pensé en fait
on dirait qu'il partent
personne ne bouge vous entendez vous
êtes qui
il nous manque 100000 dollars dis-moi où
est cet argent on a assez joué ma chérie
alors il
faut que
sais-tu touche un cheveu de mes filles
je m'assurais personnellement tirer
reste je vais récupérer les filles je
suis fait pour ça c'est la vie de civile
à laquelle je m'habille pas
ça c'est pour ma femme ça c'est pour mes
filles
ton heure est arrivé